alors les sirènes ont retentit vers 5h
du matin mais les premières informations
sur des frappes et les premières
explosions qui ont été entendus c'était
beaucoup plus tard après 8h heure locale
il semble que c'est la rive gauche du
Nièvre qui a été frappé ce matin donc un
peu plus loin du centre-ville la
banlieue est si vous voulez c'est
essentiellement des infrastructures de
génération et de distributions
d'électricité qui sont ciblées ces
derniers jours il y a deux stations de
génération d'électricité centrale je
veux dire dans ces district donc on peut
supposer que c'est ces endroits là qui
ont été les cibles mais on a uniquement
les informations préliminaires les
autorités ne donnent pas de détails sur
les adresses précises c'est aussi une
décision délibérée de la part des
autorités de ne pas donner trop de
détails trop tôt pour ne pas aider les
Russes à correcter les tirs mais il y a
eu une interruption
l'électricité ce matin cela a duré
peut-être seulement cinq secondes dans
le quartier où je suis mais des voisins
ont confirmé que chez eux aussi donc
visiblement il y a quelques
perturbations sur le réseau et ce n'est
pas uniquement Kiev qui a été frappé ce
matin notamment j'ai dormi une ville à
2h de route à l'ouest d'ici qui est très
rarement ciblé depuis le début de
l'invasion a été touché ce matin et
selon le maire de la ville l'électricité
est coupée sur toute la ville de zitomir